en france on peut dormir ensemble
d'ailleurs on a déjà dormi ensemble
c'est bon c'est bon
on a dormi avec clara ensemble s'est
rien passé me
mettrais pas mon
cas c'est bon on va pas
mais savoir mais voilà toi c moi il ya
très longtemps
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
si
vous aimez comme frères et soeurs ça ou
une histoire de famille mais comment
est-ce qu'on peut dire
non pas je t'en supplie non non non je
vais vous dire toute la vérité ne soient
pas tels mensonges la fois par les
sk qui avait un problème de vous deux
pour que ce soir là est ce pas ça du
tout mais on n'est pas du tout mais on
sait jamais chine et ben franchement
jamais mais ne paierait que ce soit à
caraquet
alors écoutez je vais raconter hallyday
merci à mr exactement ce qu'ils veulent
je le dis je le dis ouais mais si tu
auras tu me diras si je dis qu ont pris
le volant
on a dormi il ya très longtemps y'a
combien quoi très longtemps en disant
dizaine d'années c'est vrai oui oui mais
non
[Applaudissements]
il ya six ans il ya six ans à 6 ans
6 ans alors si cette jolie 6 et on fait
passer de 11 à l'étoile reste cette
paire facteurs moi j'suis d'accord six
ans en marchand de tapis là parce que
non si c'est ton mais
jamais ou si jamais on est dessus je
sais pas je crois qu'on n'était pas
encore sûr c'est vite des mois mais non
il n'importe quoi
elle a pas toute sa tête regarder
bon alors là les chéris non mais je le
dis je le dis et je le premier mensonge
honneur je vous le dit et on a dormi
ensemble oui comme départ et ça fait on
était très amis dont la tête tout
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
va contre eric zemmour
la faute d'abord après quelques accords
à la poutre à il faudra tenir filature
je prône jocalaz exact je ne croyais pas
je n ai alors que le moment le moment
compliqué de cette soirée ce sera avec
françois caradec et moment non voilà la
raison ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'on
est très habile avait rien car nous s'il
vous plaît et jamais séparé non ça
suffit
mais jamais jamais clara et moi il s'est
passé quelque chose d'accord on vous
croirait la rade et ya prescription ça
suffit alors il racontera
c'est
madame car si top et une gêne tout le
monde
on voulait tendre à d'autres
[Applaudissements]